SPEAKER: To give you a picture
of how amazing Spanner is,
let's start at the beginning,
just creating the database.
Those of you who've
actually tried
to deploy a multi-region
database that's
highly scalable, highly
reliable and highly reliant
know that there's
like a zillion steps.
You've got to
configure machines,
you've got to set
up replication,
you've got to worry about
failover, you've got sharding.
What happens if I
have network issues?
And then there's
the operational side
of just keeping
the thing running,
having to have full staffs of
people who do nothing but take
care of machinery.
With Cloud Spanner, we
turn that into one machine.
Robert's going to bring up
the dialogue to do that.
He names the instance.
He chooses whether
he wants it to be
a single or a
multi-regional database,
and then he says how many nodes.
And in this case he picks
42, because that's always
the right answer.
So that's it.
We've now created a
multi-regional database
that has amazing capabilities
but that's getting started.
Let's look at Spanner in
an actual real-world-scale
example.
Imagine you're a ticket seller.
You want to sell
tickets to events
worldwide to
customers worldwide.
Now obviously it's
pretty important
that you sell a ticket
once and only once, right?
And it's also pretty
important that customers
get a good
performance experience
wherever in the world they
are buying their tickets.
In this example, we've
deployed Cloud Spanner
into three Google regions--
US, Europe and Asia--
all connected by
that private network
that Urs told you about.
We're also running workloads
that emulate customers
buying billions of tickets.
In this case, we're
selling at about half
a million tickets per
minute through this system,
all through a system that is
maintaining consistent version
snapshots, full ACID
support for transactions,
full strong consistency.
That's the power of Spanner as a
distributed base, a distributed
database.
Our customers get a
low latency experience,
we get good old traditional
SQL consistency.
Now, to prove that this really
is a database of some size,
let me show you the schema
behind this database.
You can see it actually
is a SQL database.
There's columns that
are joined together.
And if you look at
that ticket data table,
it has three billion rows in it.
So while we're
doing this, in fact,
we're running all this traffic
against a real SQL database.
In fact, we can actually run SQL
queries against that database
while it's being hammered
with all that traffic.
Here we have a query
and if you look
at the bottom part
of the WHERE clause,
you see that we're looking
for tickets in the US
that are still available
as of 10:00 p.m.
and how many seats they have.
So these are our top five
events with unsold tickets.
Now what's important here
is what you don't see.
What's remarkable is how
unremarkable this SQL looks.
If you've deployed
a sharding system,
your SQL is a mess
because you're
trying to have to do joins
across multiple shards
of your database.
In fact, it's probably
not even human-writable
SQL when you use those systems.
Spanner takes care of all that.
But real-world
applications aren't static,
they change over time.
What happens when
your needs change?
Well, first of all,
Spanner lets you
make transactionally
consistent schema updates
with no downtime, which is
critically important when
you're running systems that
your business depends on.
And what happens if you
get a wonderful success
and your needs grow?
Well, with the
traditional SQL database,
you better put a P.O. in
for a brand-new server.
You better figure out how to
reconfigure the new server,
you better figure out
how to migrate the data,
how to do cutover.
Or if I'm doing scale
out, well, now I've
got to add a whole
new complex middleware
layer that's incredibly
difficult to maintain.
And even that takes time
and adds operational risk.
In Cloud Spanner, Robert's
going to go back to the console
and show you how we add
capacity to a Spanner database.
We simply go from 70
nodes to 99 nodes.
That's it, we've scaled out.
That's the power of a
horizontally scalable SQL
database.
[APPLAUSE]
And of course, since we use
Spanner so much internally,
we made sure it
handles large database.
Robert's going to switch over
to the monitoring console here,
and what I want you to look
at is that graph on the bottom
left.
We've been running
this whole demo
against an 80-terabyte database.
And if you look at
the top right graph,
when we loaded the data
in, we loaded the data
at an average of 800
megabytes per second.
And we peaked at about a gig
per second of loading data.
That's amazing,
that's crazy fast.
So that's Cloud Spanner.
You create a highly reliable
performant, fully managed
multi-region
database in seconds.
Cloud Spanner is SQL.
You get interoperability in
the power of SQL queries.
You get ACID transactions.
Plus, you get advanced features
like on the fly schema changes.
Cloud Spanner's fully managed.
We never had to worry about
setting up replication,
sharding, failover.
The system actually even tunes
itself automatically over time.
So as you use it, it
learns your query patterns
and it optimizes its own
performance characteristics.
And Cloud Spanner
is built for scale.
We've been running our
largest production systems
on this for years.
So with that, I'll
turn it back over
to Urs for a little bit
more of the keynote.
Thanks.